willkommen sowie eine reportage über
lost places und über urban explorer in
jedem schweizer sind ein barocker nico
ist jedoch gerade motor der e jugend
fragt hättest nick reiz doch in die lost
places co aber wenn du kb cache das wäre
ja noch spannend sie ja absolut es ist
logisch sparen sondern die lost places
eine idee für den film eigentlich fast
überall im set in dem stall unter dem
industrieareal ja das ist ja nicht so
gestört sondern die nato will wenn sie
zahlten nicht erlaubt ist dann ist nicht
erlaubt punkt der zweite ort ist das
ehemalige model sie eine eigene linie
cloud verbinden ich hätte theoretisch
könne kamera auszahlt und einfach in new
york aber ich sehe schon recht kaputt
sie das einmal schon fertig sei und
deshalb hat entschieden es ist okay wenn
jetzt die fotos an und nicht um die
bedienen muss lerner fragt wie finden
die platz also ob es eine webseite oder
sollte es gibt wo so gebäude zeichnet
sind
also es ist ja aber so marcel j
allocation von den ort nicht tyler
deshalb in der schweiz und direkt so
einfach also wenn du ins programm zum
beispiel goss crawler der twin stunde
direkt an genau das ist das verlassene
gebäude wo doch so qsc auf dem foto aber
es gibt verschiedene blogs facebook
gruppe zum beispiel oder auch internet
city wo die auch teils sind an der kasse
genau gewusst stadt mit foto und so
weiter und so fort aber schafft das etat
von einer art wo halter im internet
auffindbar sind ist natürlich schon
viele luchse sind also mich selbst der
erst und deshalb vielleicht auch immer
so cool aus marco eine idee airbags
erinnern soll und tritt für die tolle
lost places und mit dem geld werden die
buden video zum altem glanz
und wieder eröffnet ja also ich glaube
dass punkten denn viel viel airbags das
sichere innovation von so großer alter
gebäude würde
das gibt s hotel in locarno gran hotel
lokal heißt es gab sogar so sieht filme
unter der airbag sondern auch wo recht
berühmt ist sehr schmal und der deckel
hob sogar der tourismusverein wort
gemeint so lost place erben exploring
für butter also einer kölner zahler zum
dinner um menschen begleitet worden
damit man nicht irgendwo versteckt also
effekte gefahr ist natürlich kurzen wir
haben uns gebäude kennt und die
kontrollierte auditor wechsel das sind
irgendwie scheint ja das hotel das ist
jetzt kaufte daran irgendwo mal größer
und das wird renoviert und tatsächlich
wieder eröffnet ich bezweifle aber dass
das nur mit dem geld passiert wovor der
euro-wechselkurs
ok zeit ihn zu verlassen ja auch dauer
interessant und vor allem geschichten
soja unfall total also nur das war
energie im internet noch was man so über
die immobilie kann sie finden also doch
keine wirklich stunde lang mit
recherchiere verbringen es in tabak und
der eneco betreffend der bäckereifiliale
wissen kann dass sie was ist passiert
und es ist aber so viel magie mit sega
will sind trotzdem noch geschichte von
lytro
pflicht wenn oder wo das nicht empfehle
dass sie ins feld zu können dass ich bin
dort ist sie vorsichtig sie jetzt bitte
begreift dass sie das zwar älterer
mensch gehörte sind denn wo ich glaub
sexy oder so gestorben und so viele wenn
dir kein nachkomme k das gebäude ist
irgendwie verkauft war da an wo gern aus
dem hus oder aus dem muster partieller
irgendetwas will mache eines tages aber
du bist du nonne genau was oder her noch
nicht finanziert und deshalb heißt es
jetzt einfach mal so wenn man das was
man schon mega aufwand und wo niedrigste
bin hat mir aber leid eigenleben
geschieht wären würden die jetzt auch
airbags touren anbieter und die haben
schon fast über leid ob die dortigen wir
erfahren in marketing fahrern in etappen
vielmehr will es ist ja so surreal wenn
du du bist wirklich noch fort ist und so
geschah bleibt ist das gestellt aber ich
glaube nicht dass es gestellt
da wirklich die herbert katzengruber
der nordic trophy weiß nicht ob ich das
jetzt richtig ausgesprochen hat fragt
sich heute schon wissen warum die häuser
leer sind und sie nicht abgerissen oder
umfunktioniert werden also in der
schweiz das haben die gläser sechs
airbags nicht so attraktiv wie viele
häuser tatsächlich relativ schnell ab
christa oder renoviert umgebaut und den
übernehmer zum lost places werden willst
hat in der schweiz wenig platz und
bauland und so gebäude das sind viel
wert in anderen ländern findet man noch
viel krassere sache also zum beispiel in
italien oder in frankenthal nur ganze
palazzo & châteaux wo sich vier tage
lang total unberührt sind also den
kassiert die schweiz wirklich net und
java der grund meines volkes bäckerei
wie sie wissen was macht das geld fehlt
noch es ist irgendwie nur eine app
gemeinschaft und man weiß es ist
rechtlich vielleicht einfach noch nicht
geklärt
das sind zum teil gründe wieso lost
places
existierend nächste kommentar ich finde
graffitis an lost places ein lied mit
vandalismus store das ist inhaltlich
dazu
was alle sagen grafite ist grundsätzlich
auch schön und kunst aber ich bin halt
ein europa das gebäude gehört ist dass
es rechts um chf als mainz wie es ist
und die märkte und irgendwie er zeichnet
der jankulovski schrieb wenn locations
öffentlich mache dann eine sandale
einfacher wir haben über das mit der
erbin explorer auch geredet und haben
aber nach druck aus meiner die ehre was
ist eure meinung so ist es zum beispiel
sie glaube nicht wirklich dass es ein
vandalismus tourismus geht als ort wo
die randalierten irgendwie fünf stunden
bis zum irgendwo space.com von der
lehrer das sind erste lokale lüth und
die wissen sowieso wo die auf 10 aber ja
auch theoretisch ist es so wenn die auch
öffentlich sind dann finden santana
genau wie airbags
schiedsrichters herzproblem also nicht
gesucht haben zum korea in gebäude
hinderlich sei ton einer nahezu ist
kompetent kompetenter will mir hin angst
vor negativer werbick das mandala vw
kommend unterwegs
und das wenn es einfach nicht verstand
gegenwehr der rahmen der zeitschrift
healthy hobby los und selbst inszenieren
doch manche menschen sind wie es endet
ihr sowas spannend ist immer eine chance
interessantes hobby muss man schon mal
zeiger und ich finde man kann gerade mal
darüber rede ich das habe jetzt
macht das sinn oder nicht ich glaube das
ist faszinierend ich zu unter die eine
löschung bestritten und dass man das
auch mit der kamera begleitet absolut
legitim also stefanie ok schrieb dem
wiederum verstand ganz so wie es die
manager bis der gegner habt könnt ihr
ganz schön wenn menschen bewundert
finden für office wo ich die zeit
verloren gegangen ist ja das ist
wiederum die anderem einige
schiebt du doch einmal direkt mit dem
rambazamba und machen das was sie auch
gemerkt haben wie der recherche wurde
mit sitz in vor so lost places gerät
allerdings nicht das lied einfach ins
gebäude können egal ob es nur
fotografieren oder ob sie noch
sara benz fragend und einen schlüssel
hat könnt und enkeln getötet und ein
video will man einfach spitzenmäßig
gesichtet so hängt also mitzumachen und
besitzer ausfindig machen und nachfrage
ich glaube dass kunst kommentar und wenn
es dann einfach neidisch denn ist wohl
einfach nein okay das ist sie von der
qualität danke vielmals für all eure
fragen doch das lied kamera videos
verlinkt zum beispiel zur rettung also
mein vater bis jetzt noch nicht der
ganze vorgang und dennoch anderen videos
und kanal beide male habe ich dann doch
subscriber das werk bis zum rückstand